why don't we find out what we love about
Britain and how our faith helps us to be
the best that we can but what does that
to do with
values how about we come from the
opposite way and we Define generally
What Muslim values are which is not to
have boyfriend
and mar
mar is clearly forbiding alcohol in the
Quran how many Muslims do you know who
don't so how many Muslims do you know
who smoke ganja but it's not Islam is it
she's right made so many new you know
non-muslim Friends by Just feeding them
why the hell should I bring you Curry or
bring you anything for you to think it's
way he said that it's a good thing
obviously if yeah probably you should
shut up because he want the please stop
problem okay I think that part I think
that's ridiculous yeah like the fact
that they're always trying to stop him
yeah is absolutely ridiculous no because
you know what most of the time I'm not
going to lie to you yeah generally a lot
of people might disagree with this but
generally generally yeah Abdul is saying
what is actually from Islam on some
things is very extreme to be honest like
about the going to Syria I would go
Syria that's very extreme yeah that's
very extreme for him to say but for and
that's wrong for him to say but for him
to say um it's like alcohol is not Halal
and they're all like oh come on how many
Muslims you know drink and they're
stopping they don't want to hear what
Islam actually say be yourself this is
Islam it's our religion free mixing like
like free mixing is not permissible I'm
not go and say hey don't go shopping
center go do that no that's going to
extremes there's something we need to
understand I can't come and say hey it
has to be like this if you're practicing
like that M good on you we respect that
but people have different stages you
what I'm trying to say but if you go and
say oh free mixing it's okay alcohol is
fine no sorry mate just say it's not
permissible however we find a struggle
it's a struggle for us yeah Abdul H out
of all of them has come from a place
where he's seen all of that yeah yeah
he's a revert one you know he was a
boxing champion yeah yeah I know have I
experienced islamophobia no not at all
but that's cuz your wife wi it no no no
no no no no no no honestly no it's not
no no no no no it's many factors bro
sound she hasn't islamophobia because
she don't wear hijab like that outside
she don't wear outside she don't look
like a Muslim even if she's got a scarf
on she's an old woman she looks like you
know the old women that be walking down
the street they don't know that she's
Muslim but a sister that's wearing a car
hij obviously she's going to experience
it more because she looks like a Muslim
from the outer appearance she doesn't
look like OB she's a Muslim she's a
Muslim of course out appearance is not
and she's white as well cuz maybe she
looks like old lady you know know you
get know Queen
Elizabeth okay that's the reason maybe
she's not the right person to who's
going to be islamophobic to her they
were happy to live field for 5 6 days I
tell them less clean let's clean let's
clean they find out four non-muslims
might be coming oh my God we don't find
my daddy let's clean let's clean oh my
[Music]
can you yeah now that sort of Behavior
now Abdul hak yeah he was very polite
yeah let's judging he's very polite yeah
he's saying I'm so I'm so sorry you know
I don't see can smiling at her she turns
around and walks off people are going to
say he's extreme she's the extremist so
the fact that he wants to practice
religion and a part of his religion
tells him he can't touch another
female's hand should be respected just
as the uh the the Jewish people where I
live just there Stanford Hill they have
their own schools they everything their
own police police everything yeah you
have to respect that that's Sol their
own ambulance service everything
everything you what I'm trying to say so
when a Muslim does it why is it abnormal
you know there was one Jewish guy who
was going to Israel I think and he
wrapped himself in a bag in a plane cuz
he didn't want like there was a woman
next to him yeah that's his belief you
can't see that's that's what it is see
when you walked in I thought Prince
William was
there decides to go to to war and it's
gone through our democracy and whether
you like it or not our democracy
functions no it doesn't straight up he
does no no no he has a point yeah no
he's right war is war yeah if you have a
problem with war war is war killing
innocent people just killing innocent
people there's no hey they can do it we
can't do you get it no one should do it
killing innocent Muslims innocent people
no one should do it but you know where
he's right as well he's right where you
need to understand that if someone's
doing it that's wrong it's wrong just
because it's gone through a democracy
don't make it right on my Corridor and I
invited her a couple times for drinks
and course
never that's cre a bit of special so why
didn't you just invite her to a
restaurant or one of the numerous of the
places how about a Muslim woman doesn't
go out with another man Even if it's
alcohol or not alcohol you know you what
I'm trying to say she shouldn't come
anyway it's it's simple as that there's
nothing about she just oh how about you
just invite for an orange juice instead
no mate sorry
you can to a milkshake you can go toj
how about he goes and proposes to her uh
dad for marriage yeah for marriage it
wouldn't be allowed well except his love
I have once speak
to did you he's been he's been Nando
once this guy been raised on poed
eggs Okay I accept that and thank you
but um I do apologize it offends you as
a person it doesn't offend me as a
person it's entirely your
decision I really reflect On's views on
this so a greatest respect to your
father and to yourself I will befe
that's okay a lot of people my watch and
say what what extremist so stupid should
have went this that you have to
understand that it was put in the
opposite way and this guy was asked
listen um your dad fought
fighting your dad F fighting the Kurds
for example but now we want you to come
to a Kurdish Memorial to pay your
respect to to the Cs yeah he going to be
like fam they killed my dad what you
want me to come so in the same way they
like they killed our people you know you
want us to come and pay our respects for
what you get me yeah yeah yeah so it's
equal respect and they're not saying in
a rude way they just saying we'd rather
not so yeah on the other hand you know
these people were conscripted I mean
that's something we don't do anymore so
uh I guess Britain's moved on a little
bit in terms of respecting people's
rights and moved on in terms of
respecting people's rights there's no
subscription is what I'm getting at and
now they're
fighting with their Free Will yes and
that's a good thing it's a better thing
the soldiers have chosen that
lifestyle in both Cas so before they
were forced to fight now they're
fighting because they want to fight yeah
in theory that's a democratic decision
oh and that makes it right exactly
people think democracy makes things
right no that's what I'm saying it's
ridiculous it's a bunch of a bunch of 20
people deciding what to do makes it
right and then Iraq happened
yeah exactly because exactly Iraq 1
million people killed innocent people I
mean my my wife's family are religious
not cultural so her family has been
fantastic wow that's good that's
amazing that's sick I he's going to say
there have be nightmare that's but
generally you know a lot of people who
know about this you know from my stand
up or what not it just becomes a means
to abuse so I've had people messaging me
saying that my wife's a [__] lover uh
why did one of our sisters Mar marry
monkey corilla a what I think I think
that comes from you have to be totally
uneducation you have to be you're
not no this is Islam No this is Islam
the diversity end up making it look like
none of us actually know what Islam you
see they're all disagreeing upon what
Islam is because they most of them 99%
of them are forgetting the basis of what
is based on Islam yeah Islam isn't your
feeling Islam is what's from the Quran
and the Sunnah he's bringing that for
and you're just laughing at him because
you think Islam is something different
which I don't know where you're getting
that from yeah the thing is that's their
desires understand the desires and
obviously the struggles of living in a
western society and we can't conform
exactly everything but the thing is
they're not even saying conform they're
saying bro that's not Islam yeah exactly
no that's desires look you can't say you
can deny as much as you like Islam is
Islam you know there's you can do
whatever you like it's clear n like is
name you know just like this but I I I
thought there was an arrogance in saying
can I call you
Ferdinand well only if we can call you
Jal who wanted to call a who wanted to
call what I don't know man but if you if
my name isman and you want to call me
aie then I should be if your name's Tom
I should be able to call you
Jalal I don't really believe in him like
that what did he say okay no no this is
annoying now what did he say what did
you say what did he say I don't really
believe in heaven and hell like he said
he doesn't believe in heaven and hell
okay listen man the show is called
Muslim like us if you're a Muslim you
should have basic fundamental beliefs of
Muslims it's like saying Christian like
us and you got a guy that says I don't
really believe in Jesus you know then
you're not a Christian mate like in the
same way if you don't believe in heaven
and hell then what kind of Muslim are
you I believe in new light and that's
like
and dark which is hell you just said you
don't believe in heaven and
hell I don't know man confusing just
changed his mind believe this I've never
heard so much emphasis on Heaven and
Hell where is the focus on life the life
you're living the whole point is life is
the whole point of life so you can get
internal
Paradise it's about obeying the one who
created you you know that's that's what
it's about I don't understand what she's
talking about El can dominate the
conversation who the hell this she's got
this you know I think like she's been
through this problem or she's been you
know is cultural she you know know you
get those individuals yeah for example
they hate their culture so much they
started to think it's Islam wait every
time she talks about something she hates
yeah yeah problem I feel like she's edl
bro I feel like she's a member of edl
listen we have got this life and we
choose to live it according to Islam why
we're Muslim no no no why does she make
it seem like for me to live my life I
have to go party drink do all this like
why do I have to do that who told you
that that's the only definition of life
I want to live my life like this soit my
will to God Almighty cuz I believe this
is the actual true form of Freedom
instead of me conforming to society and
what they expect of me and living in
some shackles that you can't
see believe in a prophet after the
prophet Muhammad and that negates the
fundamental no they don't um no they
don't come he's confusing sh of but
anyway one who says that the prophet
after the prophet
mhammed no one said that but no one said
that was he can you appreciate why that
might be hurtful for me that someone's
saying all these things about people
come from my background someone said I'm
a I'm going to ask what
they that's you have to ask yes if they
if they
C for one it
takes that
outside if if they if they say that if
if he was saying that's what he said if
they no no no no he said I'm going to
ask AIA what they say if AIA says I
believe in cursing the sahaba then he's
saying then you're a five star great
which is true if you curse the sahaba if
let's not don't Mis constru our words or
his words if you curse the sahaba if
you're a Shia like the Zia for example
you have some zis in s in Yemen yeah who
are very close to the but they have some
sort of deviations yeah then you can't
call them do you understand cuz they
don't
Cur it's not black and white like a is a
CF it's not like that was praying with
his son bunch of people come in shoot up
the entire MOS all of the men gu
including the boys because somebody
believed that they're outside of the
fold of Islam and therefore they should
die that's wrong I also believe this is
propaganda on the BBC's part against
Sunni Islam why are they not saying
about Shia Islam about how he was
sitting there and they sniper two people
killing children women who are pregnant
sh in Dam yeah so you need to understand
that there's also atrocities committed
by sh why are they not highlighting that
I feel like they have a malicious intent
against Sunni Islam because whenever
says something to do with sun Islam
Abdul whoever it is they don't want to
know but when they go party in karaoke
yeah in people just telling innocent
people shever so the fact that they just
sh that it's not fair so the ideology to
me is scary who who told you that the
person reason why your your father's
friend was killed do you think that's
wrong ask me ask you point of view I
haven't got the evidence for to say WR
right that you don't have the Divine
text evidence to say that that is wrong
you don't need divine revelation to say
that's wrong I actually agree that it is
right and there is divine revelation if
you K any if you
Inn said whoever turns the of Isam kill
him
see there you go this is this is this
this an extreme look yeah look Weist we
are called Extreme say that bro see
that's what I'm saying black and white
how the hell is it like hey left cont
everything there's a context man there's
a context there's there's a reason why
it's in place there's a non-muslim woman
saying in front of Shia girl saying in
front of you you're saying the prophet
said kill him it's not like that bro
that's ridiculous it's too much man do
that
man come on man that's frustrating look
she's crying she's
crying it's very beautiful but I'm a
London girl so the last thing I
associate with being British is greenery
and nature that we have different views
of of what britishness yours is a very
more urban mine is a bit more what
provincial a bit more sort of I don't
know city noise and you know KFC rappers
on the floor and things
like what what escal
[Music]
okay he's pret
[Applause]
to okay okay I'm here I'm
here seriously when I got back from my
run this morning Al unplugged his
microphone and asked if I had a
microphone on and um said I just want
you to know that you're the most sincere
person in's house and I don't think you
should
die and I said thanks for saying
that and then he
left I love how um you know when he
realizes he's done a mistake yeah he'll
be like oh but I agree with Nabil you
know I don't want people to say oh he's
saying he loves him and oh he loves he
says no no no it's not like that but I
love like the way his character is you
know as a person um but I genuinely
believe you know what na was saying
about him sometimes he says things but I
don't think he knows what he's saying I
think it's just like memorize just say
like I think he's had a few Brothers
around him that are a bit too excited
and oh it's about to go
down song and chicken I love song and
chicken can you take what s and chicken
you know the green stuff with like Sago
you know the green stuff like the C typu
can we do half and half cuz me and girl
bought ingredi chicken oh right yeah is
that all right yeah so
yeah chopping up and just using any
old excuse
me with my own pocket no don't get in my
face don't touch my stuff go away go
away maybe your mother didn't teach you
not to touch other people say talk about
my mother maybe you want to talk D talk
about my mother okay keep shouting don't
you dare talk about my
mother yeah only youve got man is right
oh for God sake she she me now what I
don't like
here issues you know her she just it's
like she I'm telling you I think she's
worse than Ed I think
she's just saying don't touch my stuff
man what know you're taking my stuff you
talk loud and you're abusive he was
wrong that's was wrong yeah he's wrong
what the I touch the guy's onions bro
it's my onions you get me he was
also C his C his mom you know everyone's
saying that he cussed his mom he didn't
C he said he's saying it like you know
like didn't your mom teach you some
maners no it w you talk manners do you
get me it's just gold he going to die
with is he idiot he just idiots but I
just they took his stuff he got upset
about it and he turn to pee off stuff
cuz he paid for it you're a that's what
that's W yeah the door Clos now I'll be
a big man now yeah
yeah okay please oh my God oh my God I'm
just going to assume that the onions
made him cry that's all I'm just going
to assume like you can't cry over you
going to cry over like you can't cry
over onions but onions can make you
cry I'm not trying
to
why would you cry over they crying over
that's one job
done bro they just one pound ons you
said it from the heart was so painful
for you to hear that painful for you to
hear that painful for you toar imagine
someone
s in the kitchen Marine is getting her
own Halal makeover what do you
think much
betterly from what about from your point
of view
oh get married to yeah
boy don't think but why did she do that
it was okay why did he put it no but
it's an improvement in it I don't know
no no no why did they do that maybe she
like
the what you wor a lot more better than
yest we the hij on your
tongue oh that a deep one wear the hijab
on your tongue that's that's it see
that's why old people they got some HMA
that's true man wear the hijab on your
tongue that's so true bro that's so true
forget about that see that's the thing
at least it's a progress is it like her
wearing hijab you know cuz one of the
things there's a lot of things you can
learn from Sister Mah you know there's a
lot bro because you know her name is
Marine Marine whatever it's called I'm
joking oh yeah yeah no it's good cuz at
least you having that step you get it
then you have people saying ah you're
going to dress up like that you might as
well take it off there everyone has
their stage steps said it's better than
when you were yesterday exactly so if
you see wearing a turb hijab I I bet how
many people watch that and I bet the
slum that they were telling about her
she's probably she's probably I bet
people saying that please can I thank
you all for
actually and this has been a wonderful
integration in many way so thank you for
allowing me we thank you too my mom my
nana and my sister got together and
thought sort him out I got a phone call
you're getting married by the
way okay
really thank
you a boy or a
[Music]
girl